Well, it's official: The latest episode of
The Walking Dead proves that the series is
downright terrifying again.
The season nine episode "Bounty" featured
a roughly minute-and-a-half-long sequence
that's one of the most heart-stopping Walking
Dead scenes ever.
Major spoilers ahead, so consider yourself
warned.
In 2018, longtime The Walking Dead actor Andrew
Lincoln announced he'd be stepping away from
his post as Rick Grimes, leaving co-star Norman
Reedus to ride his character Daryl Dixon into
"Main Man" territory.
Many fans of the post-apocalyptic zombie drama
worried the show wouldn't be as exciting without
Rick.
What would The Walking Dead become?
The most recent episode answers that question
for all of us: The Walking Dead would become
absolutely horrifying.
On Sunday, February 24th, The Walking Dead
aired the eleventh episode of its ninth season
on AMC, and many viewers hailed one particular
sequence as one of the most genuinely scary
moments The Walking Dead has produced in years.
"I wanted to kill them."
It all starts with Alpha, the leader of The
Whisperers cult, portrayed by Samantha Morton.
At the start of the scene, outside of the
Hilltop settlement, her cronies are holding
two men hostage at knifepoint: Alden and Luke,
portrayed by Callan McAuliffe and Dan Fogler.
Alpha wants to trade these hostages for her
daughter, who's inside of Hilltop.
And just in case that wasn't already tense
enough…
"Hey!"
Shortly thereafter, Alpha instructs the distraught
Whisperer Mother to let the zombies eat her
child:
"If the mother can't quiet the child, then
the dead will.
Natural selection."
And to think we haven't even gotten to the
really scary part yet.
Enter Connie, a Hilltop resident trapped outside
of the gates, who sprints through the surrounding
cornfield and rescues the child… or does
she?
The real horror begins when the sound cuts
out, cleverly mirroring Connie's deafness.
As Connie soldiers on, we, the absolutely
terrified viewers, are put in her shoes and
can't see or hear what's around her.
And just as the undead creeps are within inches
of Connie, Daryl and some other survivors
manage to rescue her.
The scene lasts just over a minute, but it's
undoubtedly one of the smartest and scariest
sequences The Walking Dead has ever produced.
It's a powerful testament to how horrifying
the show can be when it gets creative.
Right after the episode aired, The Walking
Dead's Cooper Andrews weighed in on the scene
with some expert analysis:
"Cooper, what does it say about The Whisperers
that they would abandon a baby?"
"They're mean."
Hopefully, The Walking Dead will continue
delivering totally demented sequences throughout
season nine and into season ten, which AMC
ordered in early February.
With the long-running series suffering a diminishing
viewer base in recent years, not to mention
a sharp drop in ratings, showrunners would
be wise to find new ways to ratchet up the
suspense.
Who knows?
Maybe former fans will give The Walking Dead
another go.
Could the show be on the verge of a resurgence?
We're sure AMC would just love that.
Fans can find out what new dangers await the
survivors when The Walking Dead returns to
AMC on Sunday, March 3 at 9 PM Eastern Time.
In the meantime, we can continue savoring
this one terrifying scene, forever and ever
and ever.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.